whenever you go to achieve a long-term
objective that the external
has a say in throw routine out the
window because the world is going to
hit you with punches all the time you're
going to have to break routine right
this is why the some of the highly
highly highly self-disciplined people
sometimes have trouble
achieving long-term things because it's
hard for them to break routine right
rich davini welcome to the show how are
my friends it's good to be here thanks
for having me
you are a [ __ ] badass man you did
buds at 22 years
old the seal team selection that's right
that's right
um but i'm not as bad as the some guys i
had an 18 year old in my class
i mean you know so i mean i went through
as an officer so i went through four
years of
college and then and then went to buds
and so
but we had we had we had guys who had
just gotten out of high school they
didn't want to join the navy and um and
they were 18 i had one 18 year old dude
who was my class and this guy was
he was one of the fastest runners you've
ever seen i mean he was a freak and he
was a smoker
like an avid smoker and i remember he'd
like be puffing a cigarette and then
we had to go for a run and he'd beat us
all on the run i mean but he he was just
that at one point and i want to get
gross right at the beginning of our show
here but um
we were running on the beach as a class
right and he had to go to the bathroom
really bad so he figured he'd just
sprint ahead
and you know ahead of the class run into
the ocean because he was on the beach
go to the bathroom and then and then as
the class passed he caught
he got back with us right that's how
fast he was he was just ridiculous but
18 years old
unbelievable is that the youngest that
you can do that yeah because uh
because in the in the states you have to
be at least a high school graduate have
a high school degree or diploma
and that's usually around 17 18 years
old and you can go and
and then and then if you join the navy
right after high school say you're 17
you go through your regular navy boot
camp and stuff so by the time you hit
the beaches of seal training you're
you're 18. but that's still that's still
insane so you can have those kids in
america though the ones that jump ahead
a few years you've got some child
prodigy
chess grandmaster that decides he wants
to be in the sales at age 14 or
something like that that might happen in
future
afterwards i would assume if someone's
that far ahead academically the seal
teams of the military is not their first
choice
so uh i don't know if that's gonna
happen but uh so what's it like you're
22 years old or you know
you're with someone who's 18 what's that
like
being going through something that grown
men with hardened military experience
for a lot of time
more life experience more emotional
stability so on and so forth
what's that feel like were there any
interesting lessons you think from doing
it so young
well you know it's interesting i think i
and i'm i don't know the exact
there's an age limit in other words you
can't be any older than
i think 29 or 30 if you want to be a
seal now i think that has to do with
some
some of the just the physical aspects of
it i mean it literally breaks your body
down
you have to be young to do that because
you're just bursting with history you
know i mean
there's a in seal training you do
obstacle courses right and there's an
obstacle course there with a bunch of
high obstacles you climb up and do stuff
there's one obstacle called the slide
for life and it's about a
it's a four-story tower that you climb
up to the top of and then
connecting at the top of that tower
there's a rope that goes all the way
down
uh about 150 yards
down to the to the sand right and you're
supposed to climb on top of that rope
and then slide down that rope to get
down off that four-story tower it's
called the slide for life
and of course someone like me who hates
heights it's always it's it's tough to
do you just have to focus and do it
anyway there was a dude in my class i
remember who
jumped on the rope at the top of the
tower slid down
only a couple feet and then fell off the
fell off the rope and fell like almost
four stories into the stance
into the sand right and this dude's like
he you were like holy holy
crap what just happened it's like 10
seconds or so he gets up and he brushes
himself off and then
keeps going you can't do that when
you're
you could that can you can only do that
when you're young because your body just
is so resilient and so
so so i think one piece is that you have
to be young because of just the
physicality of it
um i think uh you know the seal teams
and special operations holistically
um thrive on members
who can think through things can can can
um can uh utilize some experience
and and some knowledge and kind of apply
that to problems and solutions so
so going through the training young like
that is actually i think necessary
because you kind of get through that
crucible that sees if you have these
inequalities
and then you go to a team and then
you're just a learner i mean you're a
new guy for
a while and so you're surrounded now by
experienced dudes
who whereas they may not be as
physically uh
resilient as you are at that age you're
still they're the guys you're listening
to and so i think um i think that was
the lesson
it was kind of do this up front i mean
you certainly get
bonded with people i mean at 22 and 18
they're not too much difference
you know age-wise you know but um uh but
you get bonded you start learning about
people you get
you form this bond of people with people
who just go through the shared
experience and of course that experience
whether it's the people in your
seal training class specifically or guys
who've been through
you know 20 30 years ago right you all
have that commonality i'll all talk to
guys who went through they were seals in
the 50s or 60s
you know and we could talk and we joke
about the same stuff because we've all
been through that and even now i'm the
old guy right because i went through in
the mid 90s now you got the new guys
i'll talk to seals today you know
currently and they just been through
training and we can bond because we've
been through the same that shared
experience is the common denominator
which is really cool
it seems to me learning a little bit
about you that
based on what i knew about the seals i
knew that the guys were really really
smart
but it seems like you were very well
read
as a kid you were doing visualization
and manifestation and stuff
that didn't strike me as the sort of
person
whose first port of call would be to go
into the seal team
is that well is that wrong for me is
that is it common for someone who's
who's got these sort of academic
inclinations to do that well you have a
mixture i mean again
i don't think there are any dumb guys i
mean we would joke i would you know of
course
as as brothers in arms we'd call some of
our members dumb right but
but you had a you had the you had kind
of a
a spread i would say though that spec
ops guys tend to
trend towards the more intellectual
well-read
kind of uh guys who just kind of think
differently because again the job
of special operations i always said that
the navy seals
and that job is not like the movies in
the tv show so it's not like a bunch of
door kicking
folks who just run in and shoot guns and
all that stuff they're they're masters
of
skydiving the job is really to be a
master of uncertainty it's to be able to
drop into an environment that's
deeply uncertain unknown and volatile so
in the military you call it vuca v-u-c-a
volatile uncertain complex ambiguous
environments vuca environments right
the job of a seal is to drop into those
and immediately start performing right
and so to do that
requires a level of a well an ability to
calm oneself and think through
uncertainty challenge and stress but
also a level of um
of knowledge and experience to be able
to or open-mindedness or whatever you
call it to be able to say okay
what can i apply to this environment and
that takes a lot of learning i mean i
there
you know because it's so hard to get to
seal training in the first place
and the officer path is is even more
competitive than the enlisted path
i had guys in my class i was the one guy
in my class he was he had a
a college degree in rocket science
um and he could he he enlisted in the
navy to become a seal right so
um so yeah very intelligent guys
mostly um there are there are some some
of those just big dumb guys who you you
have carry the big weapons you know and
we love them too but uh and we
we tease them all the time um but uh but
for the most part yeah a more
a more intelligent force it you'll find
in in
any spec special operations most of the
navy seals the army or even in the um
in the uk sbs sas i mean it's
amazing we work with those guys all the
time and we're so similar right because
it's just
it attracts this type of mindset which
is um
i think a little bit more deep deep
thinking what were some of the
differences between you and the
british special forces if you noticed
any
um i mean
very few i would say that they they
they're better drinkers but even that
we still went toe to toe with them on
that no i mean you know
i mean very trans transportable i mean
or kind of
similar because again um you're talking
about units that have
incredible incredibly tough selection
criteria
uh the job is to do incredibly tough
dynamic
complex things and think differently um
and so we would i mean we would get on
with those guys and whether it was the
the the brits the germans the italians
the
israelis i mean all of us it was always
cool because you just i mean you know
the difference was accents that was it
but the thing is
you guys you're no matter where you're
from the end goal is the same
to be able to drop in to deal with the
uncertainty to deal with the ambiguous
situation
and they're given the fact that everyone
has the same genetic or almost exactly
identical genetic starting points there
can't be an
unlimited number of iterations that you
can go from one point to the other
you guys need this outcome so that's
right it kind of makes sense that you're
going to have a framework that everybody
feels a little bit of um
homogeneity with that totally and i
think that some differences might be
environmental
the navy seals and the sbs guys um
and the german comp swimmers they
they're a little bit more similar
because we're water we kind of water
focus whereas the sas
the green berets and um
the gsg guys in germany they're kind of
the land guys at the army navy so you
have the army navy
stuff which we always tease each other
about but ultimately we're all friends i
mean we all we all think very highly of
each other so it's really cool
what was some of the big lessons that
you took
from dropping into these environments so
you know
the experiences that most normal people
would have
going into a client pitch in an office
or something the volume has been turned
up to 11
from that right like everything the
stakes are higher the pressure is higher
the immediacy of your decision making
has to be higher
what were some of the lessons and the
the learnings that you took away from
that
yeah i think most of those came probably
after the fact or even or maybe as i
gained more experience as i got towards
the
the latter part of my career and i began
to have the opportunity to look back
on what makes us who we are and i think
i think the biggest uh the biggest
lesson is our ability to
deal with stress challenge uncertainty
to be able to process it in a way that
allows us to think
logically through it and um and that's
born
well first it's born of attributes what
you come to the what you come to the
game with
obviously because you can't make it
through training without some of these
inequalities but then that's hyper
developed
inside of a career especially those guys
who go to combat right there's a
there there is in fact a difference
between
spec operators who um spend a career and
they never get the chance to go to
combat because that happens in fact
that's the majority of guys
maybe not now because we had 911 happen
we have the war on terror
and the guys who've actually been to
combat and you know i was just having
this morning i was just having coffee
with
so hank from the book um uh you read
about
i just had coffee with hank this morning
we were just talking about this
idea that um that the training ground
buds basic underwater demolition
seal training which is the crucible
inside of what you go through to become
a seal
that's just the ticket to get in right
um and
and then if you if you're if you happen
to have the chance like we did to go to
combat
that's when the a lot of the testing
begins because that's when it's real i
mean you go to buds and you can kind of
say well they're not going to kill me
i mean you know i remember saying that a
couple times like because i was like oh
my god i'm
this is really tough everybody's like
well they they can't kill me i mean
that's not
that's not their job to kill me so in
combat it's different the
the you are in a situation where the end
yeah yeah the gloves are off and if you
do if you do something wrong
um death could be the result and so i
think i think the big lesson is
um the the ability to hyper develop your
sense and and
kind of process by which
you deal with and walk through stress
and challenge and uncertainty
and it's very similar this is this is a
similar to all
spec ops folks and probably you know
regardless of country but in my
neighborhood for example the
quick example because my neighborhood
across the street from my house
there lives a seal down the road to the
right there's another seal down the road
to the left there's another seal right
and um and i remember my wife saying hey
i'm really glad these guys are in the
neighborhood because
if if you're gone and something would
happen i know i could go to these guys
and they'd act the same way you act
and i say what do you mean by that it's
like i just i tell them and they do
immediately calm down they start working
the problem
right because that's our that's what we
do and you hyper develop that ability
and that translates to
every context of life i mean when covid
hit and we were all quarantined
i felt myself kind of like okay yeah
what's next how are we going to
how we're going to step through this
there was not really a lot of
stress or anxiety because it's kind of
like let's just walk through let's just
feel this out so i think
i think that's a huge lesson that
everybody comes away with how many
deployments did you do
oh boy i did about seven to iraq
i did about five to afghanistan and i
did uh some other ones
around the world i can't really talk
about so i mean overall i did about
13 plus uh deployments throughout my
career yeah 20-year career so
so after you've done that and actually
while you're doing that you begin to
reflect
on some of the lessons that you've
learned and then what's what's this mind
gym thing what happened with that yeah
so that so so the mind dream the
reflection happened really
most a lot of the reflection began when
i was doing that so what happened was i
i was i had the opportunity to get to
to select ends and and be
well be chosen to go through the
selection process for one of our very
specialized seal commands
um and at this particular command we
took they took
seals from other commands and then you
went through your own selection process
and you were part of this one hang on so
you've got the hardest
guys that have gone through one of the
most difficult selections
and then you put them through another
even more difficult
selection tell me about that what's
what's that about
well it's it's it's it's so that they
can actually do the job required by this
this specific command um and there's
still about a 50 attrition rate and so
and so i was there for a little while
and then they put me in charge of the
selection process and the training
process for that command
which is really where i began to kind of
reflect because i said okay this is cool
i get to look back and look at it from
kind of a 50 000 foot view so there are
a couple things that happen in there
first
one of my jobs when i took over that
position was to
look at um operator resilience um
how how effectively were we were we
performing on the battlefield and how
effectively were we actually
being able to um come back uh
you know and and be resilient be
anti-fragile kind of kind of
heal ourselves that reintegrate back
into life
that's a great yeah great way to
reintegrate and um and grow
from it and um and so on that on that
angle on that pathway um i was also
i kind of i and a couple other guys
really felt like we were
we were fine from a physical standpoint
in other words
um benching more bench pressing more
weight or running the
mile faster wasn't going to get us any
better right it had no no
applicability to combat um where we
thought the
the the gains could be made was our was
our brain was our mind and how we could
better
we could better develop a relationship
between our our our
our brain our physiology ourselves
understand ourselves understand our
internal mechanisms and
develop that relationship so the mind
gym was really an exploration
in some things some techniques and some
equipment
so that we could start exploring that
relationship you know
how can we more effectively um
hack into our our sympathetic and
parasympathetic systems how can we go
from a sympathetic response
to a parasympathetic response almost
instantaneously because that's recovery
and i used to call it micro recovery how
can we
recover between gum fights because when
you're doing that when you're shifting
your physiology that way
you are changing the chemical and
biochemical response in your system
right
sympathetic response especially high
stress ones is going to induce cortisol
right into our system which again is a
necessary chemical
but also damaging to a degree if it's if
it if it's in your system long enough
and it shuts down other
kind of critical factors in your system
when you're releasing cortisol for
example
i mean very simple things your your hair
stops growing
your your nails stop growing um your
immune system
starts to operate in different ways um
you stop creating saliva which is why we
get dry mouth when we're when we're
stressed
but there are some there are some things
that your body basically begins to
cipher energy to very critical
components and elements of your system
all necessary for
survival in stress right however our
body is also designed to shift to the
parasympathetic the parasympathetic
system is the recovery the rest and
recovery that's when we begin to make
dhea
for example in our system dhea is a
rebuilding
chemical and neurotransmitter that that
that
not only repairs the damage done by
cortisol but also starts to
it's a it's a foundational element of
testosterone and estrogen for example so
so we can in fact um through breathing
through
visualization through um through certain
visual techniques we can actually
hack into we can deliberately move our
systems from sympathetic to
parasympathetic and so
so we started exploring some ways that
we could help operators
operators train to do that and that was
the inception of mind jim i don't know
where the mind gym
is at this time because i was in charge
of it for maybe 18 months and i moved on
um but it was certainly a cool process
to kind of think through and talk about
um while we were there so not everyone's
going to need to be able to calm down in
between
two gunfights or between dropping out of
some vehicle
into a combat zone but let's say that
someone has just had an awkward
conversation with the boss
or a really bad day at work and they've
got a a 10-minute drive home
or maybe a walk home or maybe they're
sat on the bus what would be your
favorite
strategy that you could give someone or
one of your favorite strategies look
here's something that you can do
to get yourself into a mode where you're
going to be able to be with your kids to
be with you
yeah well there's so there's two parts
of that question i'll hit the second
part for
uh first okay because i think it's
important there's the recovery part
which is what you're talking about and
that's
can i kind of effectively come off of
this hype
this stress and kind of start to rebuild
my system get myself to a different
framework and reflect appropriately
um i mean visually some a visual tool
immediately that someone can use if
they're if they're feeling this
is is open gaze right this is like when
we get stressed we start to focus our
pupils dilate
so if we say for example look at a
horizon or look at something and then
just
open our gaze which means we start to
notice our peripheries we're not staring
at anything anymore we start
that's been proven to start shifting
ourselves into parasympathetic you know
coming off of sympathetic
um breathing techniques um when we hold
our breaths
right we start to the longer you keep
your breath held you start to feel
anxious right i mean we all know this
you start to feel like oh my god i got
to breathe that feeling of stress and
anxiety is that
is not in fact because our body is
seeking oxygen
it's because our body is getting um
overdosed with
with carbon dioxide right and so one of
the ways
you can start to bring yourself shift
yourself is to do what's called co2
blowout breathing this would be simply
box breathing but in a different style
so we say um
inhale for two seconds hold for two
seconds exhale for four
seconds and then hold on that bottom for
four seconds right that's co2 blow out
that's some ways you can do it
and then i think one of one a really
important way a cool one especially
if we're driving home or on the on the
the tube or whatever
and we are on the bus and have and have
some time is visualization
visualization our brains apply
different neurotransmitters and
chemicals and biology to different
situations we're in
and those situations that bring us joy
and comfort and peace come with that the
reason why we feel that is because we're
getting a burst of
really cool powerful chemicals we can in
fact visualize effectively those same
situations
and induce that same chemical response
it's the same reason why
when we when we think about bad
experiences
we get triggered and we get bad
chemicals this is the root of ptsd
the root of ptsd is is folks who
continually get triggered by a remember
by a memory of a bad experience right so
they're
it's almost like they're reliving it but
they almost are because physiologically
they're getting that
that those chemicals you can do the same
thing with great experiences
and and great visualizations i one of
the things i used to do is you know my
boys are
16 and 14 now but when they were little
they used to they used to nap take naps
on my chest i used to just
lay on the couch and they'd nap on my
chest what i mean such a
wonderful bonding feeling when you can
do that with a child
um and so i used to visualize that you
know and i'd start
feeling what that felt like and i'd get
that chemical
release right and it's a way we can
start recovering so so in the recovery
way you can do those things
but there's another i think piece of
this that we should talk about that's
important and that is how do we
how can we more effectively march
through
an environment of stress challenge and
uncertainty and that you can use some of
the same tools to do that
uh because what what we have to
understand so so we have to kind of get
into what fear is
all right fear when we're afraid and our
amygdala starts to kick in and we start
to get that fight or flight
what happens is our our frontal lobe our
conscious mind is starting to come
offline a little bit
okay um and if it if the more afraid we
get the more the amygdala starts to get
hijacked
we can actually get into what's called
amygdala hijack we mean which means
we're
we're just operating without thinking we
do something without thinking that is
our
our frontal lobe our conscious mind is
almost completely offline and we're just
acting right
um not necessarily the best response
when you are
when you when you're when it's your job
to you know operate
when you're scared right and so so what
the way we can translate this into
regular
regular life is first we can deconstruct
fear okay
fear is ultimately two things combined
it's anxiety plus uncertainty
all right um when you have both you can
have one or the other
without being afraid right you can be
anxious without being uncertain
that might be i'm giving a presentation
next week to my boss
and you know i'm anxious i know my boss
he knows me i know the presentation
um i know what i know what's going to go
on so i'm not uncertain about it i'm
just a little anxious okay i'm not
afraid i'm just anxious
you can be uncertain without being
anxious okay well that's every kid on
christmas eve
okay so fear does not exist there
when you combine the two fear starts to
exist right and so
the way you can begin and when fear
starts to enter into your system
right that's when we start getting the
amygdala response and our frontal lobe
starts to want to go offline right so
the
the way to manage that is to is to
attempt to buy down
either one of those elements either
uncertainty or anxiety
the way you do that is first you
recognize that uh what they are okay
anxiety is internally focused
okay um there's crisis which is
happening
outside and uncertainty which is all
outside of us right the way we're
processing it is stress and anxiety okay
so that's internal it's an internal
response and we can manage it by
internal ways things i just talked about
we can do open gaze we can breathe
properly we can get our breathing
that brings down our anxiety so we're
buying down one of those starts bringing
that conscious mind back online
once we start doing that we can begin to
manage uncertainty now that's a little
bit different because uncertainty is all
external
okay but the way you begin to manage
uncertainty is you begin to ask
questions about your environment um and
process the answers to those questions
so one of the questions is okay what
about this do i understand
okay out of all of this chaos what about
it do i understand and that list might
be really small but then you say okay
from that list what can i focus on
in the moment and then you decide
something and you move towards that okay
as soon as you do that you create a
dopamine reward
in your system which allows you to do it
again and ask the question again
and then move again and get another
dopamine response so so
it's literally stepping through our
challenge stress and uncertainty
and moving through the stress so an
example would be in seal training
and i remember doing this you spend
hundreds of hours running around with
big heavy boats on your head
all day all night right and i remember
being under one of these
boats and we're on the beach and i'm
like oh my god i didn't know when it was
gonna end it was miserable everything
every part of my body was hurting and i
said to myself okay there was this big
sand berm
that we're running extra i said i'm just
gonna focus until i'm gonna i'm just
gonna
run until i hit the end of that berm
okay
okay that's what and that's what i did
as soon as i did that i created a
dopamine reward all right it was a
meaningful step for me
and once i got that open reward i was
like okay now what i'm going to do
i'm going to run to that or i'm going to
do that i'm going to pick my next thing
and so
we can manage uncertainty first anxiety
and then we can manage uncertainty by
constantly kind of looking at what that
horizon that next verizon is
making it as long or as short or as long
as we'd like right because it can be
like i'm
just going to make it to the next meal
or i'm going to make it the next 10
seconds whatever meaning whatever
provides meaning for us hitting that
hitting that goal getting the dopamine
reward and then doing it then
all right this in fact is what almost
every one of us does
unconsciously if we can think back to
how we've made it through
a really tough experience we've
basically chunked it
in meaningful pieces that mean something
to us and we've just moved through we've
we've just taken it step by step and
we've just we've defined what those
steps are the per the patient going
through cancer will
will say when they're going through
chemotherapy i just all i wanted to do
was
get through the next session right that
was my goal right
i talked to my buddy hank who's in the
book and he said when he was first kind
of
going through all of his stuff as a as
someone who lost both of his legs he's
like
he's like rich sometimes i was just like
just make it the next hour that's it
just make it to the next hour and then
i'll pick the next hour right so
but this is in fact neurologically
what's happening was we're managing it
so
so i think long answer but those are two
pieces and parts of those questions that
i think could help people
what about if you wanted to turn it on
its head what about if someone is
too parasympathetic and they need to get
themselves into
a more energized state we got any
strategies for that
well so breathing is a is a well focus
and breathing right so you can
if you focus on something you're you're
actually starting to you're
starting to shift a little bit um but
breathing is also something as well you
can
you can breathe more oxygen so wim hof
has some great breathing techniques
where you're super oxygenating
your system and you're and you're
getting more focused right
and um and so i'd have to look at some
of the breath work stuff but there's a
lot of good stuff on breath work that
can take you either way you can get
recharged
um i think deep fat deep breaths that
are fast
will um will help you get more focused
um
visualization you know in the active
sense can help you get more focused
i mean music is one thing that changes
state you know and um i know i love
metallica it's one of my favorite
and i love heavy metal but metallica's
one and metallica in some cases relaxes
me it takes me off
but sometimes it fires me up too i can
use it for both things um
but yeah certainly you can use music to
get yourself you know fired up as well
so yes you can go reverse
have you got any idea what would be
optimal for someone
if they wanted to let's say give a
presentation i'm thinking about like a
common situation that someone's about to
go into
that they're stepping into this into
this environment
but they need to have the right amount
of energy but they also need to be calm
it feels like a challenging balance to
go through here
yeah yeah well the the way you define
that state um
would be alert a bit calm right um and
so
and and really what alert but calm is
and really the way our systems are
designed
is it's a it's almost um a wave
a it's a it's a gentle oscillation
between
sympathetic and parasympathetic right in
other words it's not you're not just one
or the other
you're you're almost kind of just almost
in a sine wave you know going back and
forth
and i think that's um i think that's
going to be different that that type of
that type of state is going to is going
to be different in terms of getting
there for every person
but you almost want to be just i think
exciting
kind of a a calm excitement right i mean
every
the the good news is all of us as human
beings can draw upon our own experiences
to figure out what this feels like for
us every one of us has
felt this you felt a time where like oh
my gosh i'm
i'm fired up but i'm like really calm
and focused i'm like this is
i'm like almost in the zone this is what
kotler talks about that that would be
actually flow state the flow state would
in fact be that oscillation between the
two right and so
uh and so my advice would be think back
to
situations where you felt that and ask
yourself okay what are those
first of all what was the situation
right because you could probably get
back into it but what were those
triggers that allowed you to get there
and feel that way it's almost like that
um that
feeling that you're you're just at the
edge of your capability but it's not too
much
and not too little to be bored yeah man
it's a hell of a drug that's right
that's right and so uh and so how do you
get there and i think anybody who's
going
um is is is kind of going down pathways
for the first time
it's going to take a while i use public
speaking as a as an example i i
left late the navy and i hate i hated
public speaking you know i just like
that's i don't like the idea i'm nervous
and i said well i should probably do
that i should probably do it more
because i should choose something that
scares me
and so i started doing it the first
first year or two
i would say of public speaking i'd feel
those butterflies i'd feel nervous i'll
be like okay i don't know you know
but then i and i just kept on doing it
and it started clicking and now
i mean i you know before going up on
stage it's almost like
i'm excited to get up there i'm not
overly excited because it's not like oh
i want the applause but
it's so i look there's a little bit of
nervousness but i'm i just
feel more flowy in it and um and i think
it just takes practice
you know so so anything we want to do it
just takes practice to get to that state
i love the suggestion of music it's
staring everybody in the face
like it's such an obvious solution what
is a song that gets you
think about anyone who's ever done a one
rep max in the gym you shouldn't have
done it to silence
in fact here's a here's a cool thing for
you so i have a buddy who's a
british champion powerlifter one of my
best buddies
and he has a number of songs that he
only uses for pr attempts yeah and
they're like sacred to him
yeah so he he almost kind of accrues
this mystical power
and if it comes on if he's if it's in
the car the radio goes off if he's in a
shot but i don't think
this sort of music would be played in
the local supermarket but
um yeah and that he keeps them sacred
yeah
and it's because this is associated with
a particular type of state that he wants
to get
in yeah they're trigger points um and
and honestly the good news is you can
actually do this with your physiology as
well i mean you can actually
um if you if there's music for example
that charges you up because again i mean
you know in a power leaping environment
you're going to have music accessible to
you you may not have that same music if
you're going to give a talk to your
to some people or just listening to some
metallica in the in the hallway outside
of the meeting room yeah
although one time i did even talk and
they're like hey we're going to play a
song before you walk up do you have
anything say play metallica right so
they played metallica i was like oh that
feels great right so
but the the idea is you can actually if
you have that music that actually
triggers you gets that way
you can actually start to do things
physiologically that
help with that trigger i mean you can i
mean whatever it is it has to be
somewhat unique something you don't do
all the time but i mean if it's like
you know pound your chest three times or
or do i mean snap your
whatever it is whatever that
physiological movement
you can make that's a little bit unique
you can start attaching that
to that particular trigger and then you
don't need music at all
right as you you do it enough and you're
going to get the same
response um without the music right so
so we can do this to ourselves we just
have to like
that's really [ __ ] cool it has to be
unique though right because if it's like
if it's like doing this like i do this
to my beard all the time i can't it has
to
just like that just like your buddy he
will turn off his song um if he hears it
any other place it's because he doesn't
want to dilute
that trigger um if you do if you pick
something with your physiology it has
the same thing you have to has to be
something unique that you won't dilute
accidentally
by just doing in everyday life right so
yeah man so you talked about stephen
kotler there and we had him on earlier
this year
awesome guy really really loved his book
you
highlight the difference between optimal
performance and peak performance
obviously his was a primer on peak
performance
and your new book the attributes is
drivers of optimal performance how do
you define the distinction between that
yeah he and i he's a good friend he and
i in fact he and i met while i was
running the mind gym uh that's when i
first met him and
brought him in yeah in fact uh his his
previous book stealing fire
is uh that if you read that first
chapter is about me um he and i wrote
no [ __ ] way yeah we wrote that
chapter together so um
so so we've talked a lot about this and
i think he he would um
he would say he defines peak a little
bit more broadly than i do um which is
fair and he does some awesome work the
way i define peak i just
i try to think about elemental human
performance who are we at our most raw
and try to get down to some very simple
semantics because i think that helps
people
peak if you define it is simply an apex
right and it's an apex from which you
can only come down
and the professional and it has to be
scheduled and prepared for
and planned for right the professional
athlete plans
and and conducts himself or herself
their whole week to peak for their
events at the end of the week right the
american football player
does that all week so they can peak for
the game on sunday okay
nothing wrong with it uh not practical
in everyday life and certainly special
operations life
because in special operations you never
know when the end is coming
okay or when the end is when the end is
even near so we perform optimally
optimally optimal performance is
how can i do the very best i can in the
moment whatever the best looks like in
the moment okay
sometimes that best looks like peak it
looks like flow states and everything's
clicking it's awesome right
sometimes my very best in the moment i'm
going step by step i'm head
down it's gritty it's dirty it's hard
it's ugly right
um that is also performing optimally
right and i think what optimal
performance allows us to do is a couple
things first
it allows us to pat ourselves on the
back for performing through
challenge and stress okay even though i
just did that and it was ugly as hell
i'm we still did it right we used to
joke sometimes we do missions like man
that was not pretty at all right but
we did the mission i mean we got it
accomplished we did the best we could
with what we had
right so it allows us to pat ourselves
on the back when things don't
feel clicky and flowy and pretty but
more importantly it allows us to
approach
performance in a much more um i think
responsible and healthy way right um i
don't need to be peaking when i'm
driving to the grocery store
okay i can i can basically manage my
energy states
so that i'm using exactly the amount of
energy i need to in the moment
not too much not too little um but
but conserving because when i need to
peak i have it i can peak on demand i
can go up to a 10.
you know but then once i stay there for
a while i know i can come back down and
in some cases have to come back down to
a two or three
so i start to recover inside of my
inside of my day
right and i think if we think about our
days this way
we can start understanding where we can
actually in
inflict some of those micro recovery
moments right if you're at work all day
and you know
hey my afternoon meetings usually a bear
this morning things usually
pretty uh pretty hard but there's
usually a mellow period in the morning
or whatever or
in the um lunch time whatever you can
start saying hey i'm going to modulate
myself as i go
so that i i know when i have to be on
and peek and then i know when i can
i can actually and then you you if you
get good at this if you practice it you
don't even have to plan it ahead right
you say hey
i got a moment here i'm gonna take i'm
gonna take five minutes you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna take two minutes at my
desk to visualize
before i walk into my next meeting i'm
going to take
10 minutes on my drive home to listen to
some really great music to get me in a
great state so that when i get home
i can be right there with my kids and
i'm not i'm not bringing what i have
home with me
and so i think if we looked at
performance if we look at performance
from an optimal standpoint
it allows us to be more human for the
duration of
of of life which is inherently
unpredictable yes smearing that peak
performance across time
right because you're totally correct
like the ability
to move in and move out to speed up and
to slow down
that is where the difference is going to
be made because it's going to permit you
you need to match the output to the
demands
that's precisely with the analogies to
work outs are fairly obvious here but
you know if you're running a marathon
you don't go out at a sprint that's
right
well or you you sprint in certain
moments right you know and though i was
working out with a buddy of mine he was
he actually is a trainer
it was about a year ago and he was
making me push these sleds you know
these weighted sleds
and um and it was over about i was close
like 50 yards or something
and he was timing me and i said to him i
said to him what are you timing he said
well i'm timing your
i'm basically measuring aerobic versus
anaerobic capacity
so i'm timing how fast how much power
you have when you start your push
and comparing that to without your power
state as you get to the end of the 50
yards
and i said okay what are you well what
do you um what are you finding what am i
doing you say well interestingly enough
you
you come out when you when you push out
initially
you basically start at the same pace
that you finish right it's even
the whole way um i said well how do you
do it he's like i always start and i'm
like i like start really powerfully and
then i slow down as i go
and i said to him he had worked with a
bunch of seals and said what do you find
seals usually do he said seals usually
are like you
um they're much more aerobic in their
approach and it made sense to me because
the navy seal what you train yourself to
do is you never look at a situation
anaerobically you said you look at a
situation aerobically because you never
know how long
you're going to be going you know when
you start a mission you have an idea
and you hope that the mission will have
a certain duration but you don't know
what's going to happen
it could go it could go for days you
know you know so
so you you train yourself to always
think aerobically and then
that gives you the capacity to go
anaerobic when you you know on demand
and i think we can think about life the
same way
i did that today i had a workout this
morning and i pushed it far
far too hard and anyone that's done the
acid bath crossfit workout
you know what happens you cross that
anaerobic threshold and it's just a
ticking
it's just a ticking clock it's like it's
like
watching an asteroid very quickly come
for you
and you're like there's there's a wall
here okay so we've distinguished between
optimal and peak performance and then
there's also a distinction to be made
between attributes and skills
yeah yeah so this was the other part of
when i was in running that training and
selection i had to
uh i i was tasked with more effectively
articulating
why guys weren't making it through why
we were losing 50
of these top guys because we had the
excuses we have the the explanations we
had were unsatisfactory there were
things like well they couldn't shoot
very well they couldn't do this and
these were experienced seals obviously
they could shoot obviously they could do
this stuff
this is when i began to separate these
things because there's a difference when
we look at performance
we often focus on skills and the reason
why we focus on skills is because skills
are highly visible and they're highly
measurable
so skills just to break it down are not
inherent to our nature right we
we're not born with the ability to shoot
a gun or or ride a bike or throw a ball
we learn to do those things we're taught
to do those things and they direct our
behavior in known situations and
environments right here's how and when
to shoot a gun here's how it went to
throw a ball or ride a bike
as such they're very easy to assess
measure and test you can see how well
anybody does any one of those things
what they don't tell us is how we
operate when the environment becomes
unknown and uncertain
when we when we're deep in in challenge
uncertainty stress because it's very
difficult if not impossible to apply a
known skill
to an unknown environment right this is
where we lean on our attributes
attributes are more innate or they are
innate right all of us are born with
levels of situational awareness
adaptability of patients
and of course they develop over time and
experience certainly but we can see
levels of the stuff in small children
elemental human performance who are we
at our most raw which is what i'm
interested in and attributes don't
dictate our performance attributes
inform our performance right so
my son's levels of resilience and
perseverance for example
informed the way he showed up when he
was learning how to ride a bike he's
learning that skill
and he was falling off a dozen times
okay so they inform how we show up
and then because they're hitting the
back then they're hard to assess they're
hard to see in assassin measure
you can't necessarily sit across the
table in an interview process when
someone's trying to hire someone and
assess someone's level of resilience or
patience
right um they show up the most visibly
visibly during challenge uncertainty and
stress which is why the laboratory i had
was such a good one because everything
about steel training is
throwing guys in stress right so so what
i did in the book was i said well
this is you know i kept on getting
questions from teams and businesses hey
we keep on putting together these dream
teams
um best sales person best marketing
person best
lawyer but whatever best best best put
them all together
and it works for a little bit but as
soon as the plan
changes or there's a turn or things
don't go as planned or
uncertain the teams start to fall apart
they start turning toxic
and they said what's going on i said
well it's quite simple you're you're
you're picking your team based on the
wrong things you're picking your team
based on skills versus thinking about
attributes
these attributes are what tell us or or
are what
indicate our performance in uncertainty
challenge and stress and so
um and so the good news is we have all
the attributes okay
but the difference in each one of us are
the levels to which we have each so
adaptability is the one i usually use as
an example if 10 is high and one is low
i'm probably level eight on adaptability
what does that mean that means when the
environment changes around me
outside of my control it's fairly easy
for me to go with the flow and roll with
it okay i just adapt
someone else might be a level three okay
which means the same thing happens to
them
it's difficult for them to go with
farther yeah
much less tolerance again no judgment on
where we show up all of us
if we were to line up all the attributes
like a row of dimmer switches on the
wall we'd all have different levels our
lines would look different
no judgment there okay because you know
it'd be like judging our hair color
um the the idea is can we
figure out where we stand on some of
this stuff so a can it can give us
information on how we perform
and b we can start making some decisions
as to whether or not we want to improve
and develop
certain attributes that we might not
have a lot on but we want more of
i had james clear's atomic habits in my
head while i was reading it
and i thought of you don't rise to the
level of your skills you fall to the
level of your attributes
yeah i would i would uh i would so i
would say i would say i would add
something because because there's a
saying in the teams you don't rise to
the level of your uh in stress you don't
rise to
you don't rise up you basically fall to
the to the base level right so
so this is why training and skills is
important but
but we have to not over emphasize it if
you can do something at a very
unconscious level if you train so much
that you can do without thinking about
it
it's it's probably a good bet that when
things get
rough and ugly you'll still be able to
do that right that's almost like
making a skill an attribute in a way
it's internalizing it so much that it
becomes second nature the boxer
that's slipping punches without
consciously thinking of it
that's right but we have to understand
that if someone is for example
inherently um uh
unadaptable okay they can train
a skill in a known environment all they
want and become really good at
it in a known environment as soon as the
environment changes though
that low adaptability is going to going
to kick in so they may in fact not be
able to execute that skill
as as deftly as they could in that known
environment right so
so there it's all interrelated and i
thought about writing the book
i i could talk about how these all
interrelate into play but it would have
been a thousand page book and
it wouldn't have been published yet so
um so it's really just a basic intro
on uh the reader saying okay how does
this show up for me in my life
and then if you're a business owner or
inside of a team how does this show up
for my team because the best teams
are made up of attributes that mesh
right and and
and balance each other and support
mutually support each other that's the
best team so to know this stuff is
actually really good
are you tempted to create a hierarchy at
all or are there some that you think
are fundamental and enable others to
come out of them
you've mentioned adaptability a fair bit
it seems like
that would be more of a foundational
type of attribute than perhaps some of
the others
yeah yeah i did i thought about um
uh creating a hierarchy but uh what i
recognized is that i it was probably
irresponsible for me to do that
um a i don't have any psychological
background and b i just think
everybody's so different and so
subjective
and the attributes play off of each
other in very unique ways right so
so someone who is um who has low
adaptability for example
but might be high on open-mindedness
they might be
perfectly okay that there's balance well
because the open-mindedness helps the
adaptability right
um someone who is um let's see another
example someone who is
uh low on um
say situational awareness okay um
but high on um uh
well what's another one let's see high
on cunning or something like that you
know that that could play off of it
um someone who's uh
a little bit higher on uh narcissism but
also high on humility
wonderful combination there you know so
so again
the problem they're not just seen in
isolation right they're all very
interrelated
that's right now i don't want to dodge
your question so i won't because i
because if you put my
back to a wall and said rich what are
the most important i would say
from a human aspect and in life i would
say the grit attributes
probably are are
probably edge out the other ones in
importance in other words just to be a
human
in this world takes some courage takes
some adaptability takes some
perseverance takes some resilience okay
um the world changes everything changes
over time so that means
we need to be at that if you're not
adaptable you'll be you'll be a dinosaur
right not a frog
um there's going to be stuff that scares
us all the time right if we're not if we
can't if we can't be a little bit
courageous we're going to be sitting in
our
houses you know for the rest of our
lives right so i think the grid
attributes if i were to place them if i
were to eat
one or a set of of attributes above the
rest i would eat that first set that
grit set
above the rest but that's that's the
that's the best i'll do just a little
bit more scalable
right it's just able to be a little bit
more sort of diverse like that is there
someone from
your experience have you met someone
that comes to mind is like the most
gritty human or some of the most gritty
humans that you've met any
stories from back in the day well so
again
hank and i were talking about this when
we're having coffee um grit is also
subjective and we both i mean we both
would say
i mean you know there are people who are
very gritty in certain situations
who in other situations you know fall
into puddles right
um and who's to choose to uh who's to
kind of
place value on someone's ability to move
through chess
challenge and stress i mean there's
there are kids in the
children's hospitals who who are
fighting cancer who have more grit in
their little finger
than most navy seals i've ever met in my
life right i mean so um
so yeah i don't know i think i've
certainly met tons of people with tons
of grit but i mean their
grit is everywhere i think every human
being has has some of it in them
um and there are stories abound of
people who you're like oh my gosh
how the heck did that person get through
that
and um and you look at their ability to
kind of
gut it out and you're like i don't know
if i could have done that you really
admire and respect that so
so uh so the answer is yes i've met
those people but but they're all around
us and it's inside of us too
i've got some buddies that are going
through a couple of different fellas
that
mates that are going through like some
challenges at the moment and i'm
watching it unfold
so i get the benefit almost of being
able to iterate on these learning
strategic learning experiences
each time i have a phone call or a text
message or whatever and um
it's insane man like the the level of
resiliency
that they're showing is just like it
blows my mind
but on the flip side it's very domain
specific
you can imagine a guy who is absolute an
animal on the the field of battle but
really struggles when him and his missus
have an argument
you know so yeah not only are the
attributes themselves also
interdependent but within different
domains some of them interact in a
different way
i've had this in my head ever since we
started talking have you looked into
behavioral genetics much
i haven't much i've heard of it yeah but
uh but yeah it's one of those things i
have on my notepad to uh to look into
yeah
so i think there's so much crossover
between what you're talking about here
so the heritability of particular traits
right right that manifests so
how much is your height dependent on
your parents height
how much is your likelihood for
depression or schizophrenia or penis
length or
uh like marital um instability
how much is this heritable and it it
maps
so nicely onto the attributes and the
skills
model that they don't dictate but they
do inform
they do inform and this you bring up a
great point so i want to i want to just
go back to one point you brought up
because i think it's important to hit
then i'll hit this next one
the fact that you said you're you're
being you're on phone calls with these
friends who are going through
this stuff that is of enormous
importance okay because a lot of these
attributes
um they also are enhanced by help by
others others help us
be more courageous other help others can
help us be more adaptable others can
help us be more
resilient right so so if you are someone
who's going through
something hard go find people go find
help they will help you do it and if
you're a friend
who has a friend going through something
be someone who can help them right so
so i think that's number one number two
in terms of the
uh the kind of nature or nurture part of
this i think i think it's
it's really important uh for us to
understand the way i would say
you know i'm i'm all for nature
like how do i show up in the world okay
um but the way i would say it is this we
are all
just like odd we're all human right so
but just like cars
we're different right so there's some of
us are ferraris some of us are suvs some
of us are
jeeps okay and there's no judgment okay
because the jeep can do things the
ferrari can't do and the ferrari can do
things that jeep can't do
it behooves us to look under our hood
and see kind of which vehicle we are
because
we may be a jeep that's been trying to
run our ferrari track
know thyself man now the cool
thing about our about this life that
we've that we have
is that if we are a jeep that's running
on a ferrari track
we can do that we can choose to be a
jeep running on our track
but to run better on the ferrari track
as a jeep it'd probably be good to know
what you can work on to run better on
that ferrari track as you
could be a ferrari track running you
could be a ferrari running on a jeep
track if you want
it's up to you um so what it provides is
know thyself what it provides is the
ability to understand where you sit
what your performance and how your
performance looks in whatever niche that
you found
and then make some decisions do i want
to am i oh gosh
that's it i'm in the wrong thing i need
to i need to switch or say you know what
i'm in the right thing i love this i
just know now why it's been such a
struggle and i know what those things i
can work on so i think you're right
nature nurture we can we can put
ourselves into experiences
that help develop these attributes that
we're low on
um sometimes experiences are thrown at
us without our without our consent that
help us develop these attributes
that we're low on um and we can use this
the these these types of
experiences to kind of you know get
better at some of these things
we just can't we just can't develop or
learn an attribute the same way we learn
a skill okay
it's not it's not translatable and a
quick back of the envelope will test for
the audience members to
to decide whether it's a skill or an
attribute because they could get
conflated
is to ask yourself can i teach it or can
it be taught if the answer is yes
it's probably a skill if the answer is
no it's probably an attribute right so
the example would be chris you said hey
rich
i want to learn how to shoot a pistol
and hit a target hit a bullseye every
time
well i could take you to the range and
teach you how to do that within two
hours right that's a skill
or you say rich i want to learn how to
be more patient right
i can't teach you how to be more patient
okay um to develop an attribute take
self-motivation self-direction and it
takes a willingness for
that individual to deliberately place
themselves into environments
that develop and tease that attribute
right if you're someone who is inpatient
who wants to develop patients
you must then go find environments that
develop your patients right i don't know
what that looks like maybe you go
deliberately drive in london traffic
uh or you go wait in the um longest line
at the
at the the grocery store whatever it is
or you have kids that's a great one
um to develop patients but um but you
have to it's it takes
oneself i can't teach you an attribute
um you have to you have to do it
yourself
dude i heard this guy on the show ben
aldridge he
spent a year after he suffered with some
really bad panic attacks and anxiety
he decided to do uh voluntary exposure
therapy essentially
but for everything like this guy did
hundreds of them
whether it was he had a fear of needles
so he created an anti-bucket list
all of the things that he really didn't
want to do had a huge fear of needles so
he worked himself up to getting
acupuncture all over his face had a
massive
massive fear of heights so built himself
up to walking on one of those
um overhangs that's got a glass floor on
it it's like there's some huge towers
somewhere
uh he ran a marathon he climbed everest
inside of his house going up and down
stairs
uh he went up and spoke to strangers in
the street he waited in a queue he drove
there's a ring road called the m25
outside of london
and he purposely went and just sat in
the traffic just to get annoyed
to develop his patience to be so what
you're saying aligns perfectly with that
i really want to dig into
you know people are listening and they
think i want some more
compartmentalization or situational
awareness or whatever
um can you just dig into those
principles of somebody looks under the
hood
they've done the self-inquiry everyone
that's listening is radically sensible
they're
unbelievably keen to do this sort of
stuff what are the principles
i want an attribute or if i find a
deficiency or there is a lack that i
really think my life would be better if
i was able to
improve in this particular area yeah
what are those three principles again
can you give us some examples yeah in
fact i so
so i'll give you a general i actually
put workbooks on the
website that someone can get and they
can actually
uh the attributes.com yeah and you can
go and
they're workbooks for the grit
attributes the mental heat attributes
and the drive attributes and and it goes
through each
individual attribute and gives you some
tips and clues on how to develop that
specific one
the overarching thing is to is to say to
yourself okay i have an attribute that
i'm low on and i want to develop okay
first of all let's
let's do some self examination and ask
okay what is it
what are those environments and
situations that i'm
most uncomfortable in okay so take
something like um
uh take something like well let's let's
just let's just use adaptability okay
um i i want to develop my adaptability
all right so i need to understand
what that looks like in my life okay um
maybe i'm traveling and when the plane
is delayed or something i get very
anxious you know i you know
i just it doesn't sit well with me um
you may want to then this is this is
radical you may want to then say okay
i'm going to develop this so i'm just
going to
i'm going to go to the airport and buy a
ticket somewhere okay and i'm going to
go
to a new place and i'm not going to do
any i'm just going to i'm going to drop
onto the ground
and then figure it out i'm going to just
decide to do that i'm going to go find a
place to stay i'm going to get
whatever it is um put yourself into
situations that actually test and tease
that and develop that now
i want to um warn people like you know
even courage i want to warn people you
don't have to be
extreme on this stuff you can start
small if you are someone who
um courage is a is usually common one if
you're someone
who finds fear you know it feels fear
in talking to people you're an introvert
um it might be as simple as like you
said that guy did you know you
you just start startup conversations
with strangers you know that is going to
feel very scary to you
um here's the cool thing about fear
though and um and this is something we
can all use
when we um when the when the fear
response gets gets an issue when the
amygdala begins to
uh to kick in okay we are we are given
two choices and we both we all know the
choices
fight or flight okay we've often heard
of a third choice called freeze but
really what they found neurologically is
freeze is simply an oscillation
between the two you're basically just
sitting there trying to decide all right
so it's really just fight or flight
um when we decide to step into our fear
to fight okay that means step into our
fear
um as soon as we do that where our
bodies give us a dopamine reward
okay our bodies are designed to do that
because we had to that nature had to
give us a reason
to go find new food or else we would
always flee
or or else we'd always or we'd waste
away right i mean so so
what we have to understand about fear
and anxiety and all this stuff is
it's it's designed to get our systems
moving okay
when we are hungry our body begins to
feel stressed and anxious
that is designed to get us to go out and
feel good and find food um
same thing when we're lonely it's
designed to get us stressed to go find
out
find companionship right so so we can
begin and so this so our bodies began to
give us
reward systems when we actually decided
to do that
so if you are afraid if you find
yourself afraid of things
um all you need to do is just start
testing yourself and
and stepping you know stepping into
those into those spheres
and you'll feel a dopamine reward after
it i'm not saying that the act is going
to be feel good right
i don't like roller coasters okay when i
decide to do a roller coaster i'm not
gonna i'm not saying that the roller
coaster feels good doing it
but i am saying once i'm done with it i
feel great for having done it
okay i remember in college there was
this girl i had a crush on and i had a
crush on her for a long time
and she seemed so unattainable and i
said to myself one day you know i said i
need to do something right and i saw her
one night out
and so i went up to her i asked her out
okay and she said no i'm so sorry you
know thanks so much for asking but i
have a boyfriend right so i didn't get
you know they th it's not a happy ending
in terms of me getting the girl
but i still to this day i'm so happy i
did it right
because i actually tried i actually
stepped into my field think about how
meaningful that situation is that
decades later you're still able to
recall it
yeah but but here's the thing chris i
think every human
probably listening to this can think of
a time where they actually
stepped into their fear they did
something that a little scared and they
probably still feel good about it
okay they probably do um because that's
how powerful that's a dopamine hit that
we're getting and so
and so now i want to say fear is also
designed to allow human beings to
appropriately risk mitigate
or assess risk right sometimes the
appropriate thing to do is flee
okay or flight right because it's never
a good idea to fight a bear right so
so but the idea is can you get yourself
into a position um when you start
feeling that fear where you can actually
make that decision
okay is this something i want you to
step into or is there something no
kidding i need to flee right so
um but if you do decide to step in
you'll get that reward you'll get that
that uh that hit and you'll feel good
and you just practice that just like
this guy you just said
um uh did he was basically he was
practicing this stuff and i'm sure that
he was able to continue to do it
as he did it more because he was feeling
the effects of that dopamine reward
system
does that mean that fear increases our
vigilance
is that is that reflected in the
in the brain at all so so it's a it's an
interesting question that's a little bit
complex because um
and again i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm a fan
of neuroscience but i'm not a
neuroscientist
when we are when we're afraid when our
body goes into
fear response what typically happens is
we we narrow our focus
okay so in fact our our vigilance goes
away
because we're focused on a threat um
this is why the alert but calm state is
so important when we're alert and calm
we are actually in a state where we
actually have more vigilance because
we're able to neurologically notice
different things
um we our brains in fact react faster
when we are actually in that state um
an example would be if you're standing
if you're at a stoplight
okay and it's red and you're staring at
it waiting to
you're staring at the light waiting for
it to go green if you're staring at it
and it goes green you're gonna respond
and go
you'll actually respond faster you'll
actually hit that accelerator faster
if you're actually not staring at it
you're actually just it's in your
periphery
okay and you you see it go green in your
periphery you're actually your response
is faster
now i'm not i'm not uh advising anybody
to go drag race by the way okay
but this is also why when we're riding
our bike or running or something and
we're
and a bug hits our eye and it's like oh
my god that bug
oh my god i can't believe i blinked
right when that buck hit my eye well
we our body actually did that you know
we were we were in an
open state and our bodies saw before our
brain saw our body said oh
bug coming closed the eye so that you
know so it didn't hit us in the eye so
so we are actually the alert calm state
is the best for vigilance
um when we were when we were in a fear
state and
we it we tend to narrow focus because
our bodies are designed to
focus on that threat and and address it
and then and then get out of it so
so it's a little bit of a complex answer
i understand one of my
favorite attributes that you go into is
humor actually
yeah which i think would have been a
surprise maybe to some people it makes
sense but you wouldn't when you're
talking about
optimal performance humor perhaps
doesn't come up as one of those can you
dig into that for me
well yeah again we're talking about
neuroscience again and and neurobiology
because what laughing does
first of all laughing is involuntary
it's like sneezing okay if you laugh
it's not it's because you just you're
you did all right you know that's why
comedians are such a gift right
um when we laugh we get three powerful
chemicals
uh injected into our system two
neurotransmitters and one hormone okay
first neurotransmitter is dopamine just
talked about that that's a hugely
powerful one says hey this is good keep
doing this
um the next one uh is uh endorphins
okay endorphins are the human body's
equivalent of opiates okay
so they mask our pain runners high and
things like that that's endorphins
designed by nature to make us the
endurance creatures that we are okay
that's why endorphins exist
um so we get dopamine we get endorphins
and then we get oxytocin which is a
hormone oxytocin is known as the love
hormone okay
it's um it's a bonding binding chemical
between human beings we get
bursts of it when we when we embrace
when we you know human touch
when we have a great conversation when
we shake hands when we ask the physical
kind the acts of kindness between human
beings
induce oxytocin it's a bonding chemical
so when we laugh we get all three of
those involuntarily
right laughing makes us feel good
feel better okay um because it's
involuntary because we get burst with
these chemicals
this is why um sense of humor is one of
the most desired
desirable qualities when you're looking
for mates either male or female right
because
because it's a it's a signal between
humans that hey when things get tough
i will i will bring you up i will lift
you up neurobiologically i'll make you
laugh okay
i've never seen a high-performing team a
successful one
that hasn't had at least a couple class
clowns you know that the people who make
jokes
right when things are bad right and
bring everybody up and again
humor as an attribute doesn't mean you
have to be that class count you don't
have to be the person making the jokes
you just have to be someone who's able
to laugh right because if you're able to
laugh
it will get you through and oh by the
way we just talked about courage
this is why laughing is why humor is
also a hack into courage because
when you laugh you're getting dopamine
well dope means the same reward you get
when you execute a step into what what
scares you
so this is why anybody and anybody could
have this might have an
example in their lives if they had if
they were if they could think of a time
they were scared of something
and then someone made them laugh like
really made them not like
am i like a fake lap but really like a
laugh they they felt braver
automatically you know they felt they
felt better that fear started to
dissipate because they got that reward
system
so laughter can also be a hack into
courage as well did you guys use
morbid humor a lot and i tell you chris
people ask me what i miss the most about
the teams and it's the humor
i mean i remember i mean we allowed it
but you you that starts in buds i mean
in buds it's
there were some of the most miserable
times and we were laughing until we were
crying i mean it was that funny
um so yeah we all the time i mean this
is where
um i think these teams that do
really you know people always think you
know these firefighters cops
spec ops military folks they have this
dark humor um
it's it exists for a reason because when
you do dark stuff
you need things that help you get
through it properly it's a
performance enhancer and a coping
mechanism in one and a team building
exercise
that's right that's right and i know i
mean i unfortunately have been i've been
to far too many funerals
in my day um but uh but even at funerals
when when you're when you're honoring
someone and remembering someone
those people who could remember them in
a funny way and make people laugh
you feel so good you know you feel great
about it you
it it helps you cope because this is and
this is
again this is neurobiological which is
cool what about decisiveness
i think this is something that a lot of
people want we have a paradox of choice
at the moment
far too much stimulation far too much
information to work out what it is i
don't know what i want to do how can
someone develop their decisiveness
decisiveness is really all about
understanding
um how your how how effectively you're
bringing in
information and then to what level to
what to what extent you're comfortable
deciding to do something with a certain
level decisiveness
is the the ability to make an effective
decision with efficiency and speed
okay and those two last words are
actually are actually the most important
part of decisiveness because someone can
be good at making decisions
but it's like a long process all right
decisiveness really kind of
kind of almost bridges into this thing
we called in the military the 80 20 rule
where you you are never going to get 100
of the information that you need to make
an appropriate decision it's almost
impossible especially in a military bar
but most life
uh situations you're not going to get
100 of the information so
the idea is to get as much information
as you can in the moment okay whatever
that percentage looks like
um and then make a decision and and move
and again
when you make a decision what people
have to understand is is
um it's final but not but might not
necessarily be permanent
okay um so in other words we're gonna
make a decision we're gonna move into
that decision we're gonna execute
but i'm also going to buttress that with
some accountability and ask myself after
i make that decision
is this working is this not we may have
to change right so it's not so
so final is not the same as permanent so
you can be decisive
you can make decisions that are final
and then you buttress that with
accountability so that it might not be
permanent no leader
no true leader that any of us think of
as leaders aren't such
are our people who are are long
protracted decision makers you know that
you know decisiveness is a leadership
characteristic that most human beings
really honor and look for
i think a corollary of that is the
ability to do task switching
quickly yes you know again too much
stimulation too much information we were
not
designed to consume the entire world's
news
yeah instantly 24 hours a day what about
task switching how can people reduce the
lag time it's steven kotler talks about
this
if you knock yourself out of flow you're
looking at 20 minutes at least
before you can get yourself back in how
can people maximize
their their focus and their ability to
move between different tasks
well definitely put away the
distractions that that um that don't
matter in the moment i mean again we're
talking about a neurological thing or
our minds are neurologically jumping
between contexts and so when we're if
you and i are having a conversation
and suddenly i have my phone and it
beeps right
my brain has just switched even if i
haven't taken my eyes off of you
my brain has just jumped right and
sometimes that's the equivalent of going
from a library to a soccer to a to a
football field right
your brain's like okay what's going on
now whether we like it or not
or whether we're good at it or not that
is very energy
it's neurologically taxing and it's
energy expending uh
it's a it's a our brains only run it on
about 40 watts of power
um and task switching takes up a lot of
energy which is why
if it happens a lot we can feel
exhausted it's funny because
people ask me why we started the
pandemic all of us were quarantined okay
we're all in our house right
doing almost nothing it feels like we're
doing nothing all day yet we're
exhausted
okay why is that well one of the reasons
is because we just
we went from a lifestyle where where we
had environments
of that siloed environments of activity
right i'm at home
then i'm in my car then i go to work and
then i when i'm doing then i'm at
the gym and then i'm at home again right
it's and so our brains had
had environments inside of which we
could say okay now i'm locked into this
okay well as soon as we're quarantined
all of those contexts got wrapped into
one environment right so
so i remember i was like i was writing
the book and then suddenly i was helping
my son with calculus and then suddenly i
was making lunch and i said i was
walking the dog
and we're like okay why am i so
exhausted well the reason why is because
our brains were switching constantly you
know going from context to contact
inside one environment so it can be it
can be mentally
which turns into physically exhausting
and so is that the going back to the
triggers that we spoke about before that
the environmental cues
often prime our state for the act that
we're going to do i often talk about
this man
i have never no matter how good a home
gym is
i've never had as good of a workout or
lifted as much as i do
when you go through the ritual of
getting the bag out of the car
saying hello to the receptionist you
know put choosing the playlist that
you're going to listen to
or bitching about the playlist that's on
in the gym or whatever
yeah you get locked in these are the
triggers right you you your
physiological and physical state gets
locked into environments right this is
why i
we used to say it's it's good thing that
when we deployed you know to go to
go to go to war we weren't coming home
every night it would have been
enormously difficult
to do that job and have to switch
between the two
chunking again yeah chunking again so so
we can use these and so and it's because
these environments have
also created some some unconscious
competence inside of them right and when
i get into a car
there's a bunch of things i can do in
that car without thinking because i'm in
that car right
same thing at work same thing at the gym
same thing at home right so it
we've we've minimized and made efficient
a lot of these
tasks that are inside these silos and as
soon as they got wrapped into one
environment we're like holy [ __ ] you
know i'm
i'm overwhelmed right um but it makes a
difference
okay so how can people improve their
ability to switch between tasks
like let's say that someone has a lot of
stuff going on is there
is there anything that you've found that
works for you um
i you know there i think
it's a great question because i'm i'm a
little bit you know i would say i'm
probably
i'm a little bit better at task
switching than that compartmentalization
in terms of focusing
um whereas my wife's the opposite she
can focus and and um
uh deeply and not and kind of drop
everything off but i would say i would
say limit
eliminate all that stuff that you that
doesn't make sense
and then i think a recognition of when
you're
shifting helps right so in other words
if i'm if i'm doing email
okay i'm gonna do email right now and
then i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
deliberately understand that i'm gonna
switch from email to
talking on the phone or doing something
else i think a right i think i think
i think knowledge i mean recognizing
this stuff is
is part of the battle and that's
probably what i do again i'm not an
expert i'm still working on this stuff
myself
um but i think um knowing what's
happening
helps that metacognition that yes
totally and so i think that's that would
be my my one note
i guess i agree i listened to i can't
remember the guy's name i keep meaning
to bring him on the show
uh he was on sam harris talking about um
what people mean when they say that they
are good at multitasking yeah and he
said there's no such
thing there is no such thing as
multitasking what people mean by
multitasking is parallel processing
that doesn't exist that's [ __ ] what
you can do is switch between
different tasks very very quickly but
even that is
ridiculously inefficient here's a really
cool analogy that he used so he said
that
um in the same way that there's a
mathematical model you can use
to work out based on
where a squirrel is in a tree how many
nuts are in the tree and how many nuts
are close to that squirrel and how far
the next tree away from this
from that tree is when the squirrel is
going to give up looking for nuts in
that tree and go on
so there's a function this it's how much
work does this put
this person how much this man in a
squirrel suit how much work does the man
in the squirrel suit have to do
to get the next nut and what's the cost
of moving from where he is now to the
next place where he might be able to get
more nuts more easily
right and he made an analogy with humans
and said that we're
in the same way that squirrels and nut
forages were information foragers
because for us ancestrally information
was such a valuable resource
it was the thing that kept us alive we
never had more of it than we needed in
fact we probably had a scarcity not a
surplus
yes and now we've got the reverse now we
have an abundance
rather than a scarcity and his point is
to
try and bring constraints in to focus on
single things as much as you can to
reduce
reduce distractions another one that i
thought was really interesting to talk
about
especially given your background is
discipline and it's something that after
the last year
everyone's looking to develop a little
bit more of what your insights are
yeah i think this one the important
thing is the distinction and there's a
distinction between discipline and
self-discipline i talk about discipline
holistically
um and discipline holistically means the
ability to
uh to kind of set and
understand the wickets involved to
achieve kind of a longer term goal and
then move through those effectively to
achieve that goal
um and those goals that goal is
something that the external world
actually has a say in whether or not you
achieve in other words you're going to
have to power through some external but
what's an example of that
uh being a seal writing a book starting
a podcast uh
becoming a a surgeon okay
it's easier if i give the opposite
example self-discipline are those goals
that
the external world has no say in whether
or not you accomplish okay that would be
like i want to lose weight and eat
better
okay or work out and eat better right i
can decide that
i say i'm gonna i'm gonna lose weight
and work out and eat better right i
decide that and
i could go to the vegas buffet right and
the buffet is not going to throw
pastries at me right it's all on me
as to whether or not i achieve that goal
right those types of that
self-discipline that's those goals that
you
that only you the external has no say in
whether or not you accomplish
discipline are those goals that um that
you have that the external does have a
say right
and oftentimes they can now when when
balanced is very powerful
someone however who might be higher on
self-discipline
typically likes routine and likes to you
know like likes a like
a kind of a scheduled or ordered
schedule right
they if they're too high on that
overall discipline is hurt right because
whenever you go to achieve a long-term
objective that the external world has
a say in um throw routine out the window
because the world is going to
hit you with punches all the time you're
going to have to break routine right
this is why the
some of the highly highly highly
self-disciplined people sometimes have
trouble achieving long-term things
because it's hard for them to break
routine right
but again the best is a balance in
between so you can have you can be a
little bit self-disciplined and also be
disciplined
that's that's the balance i love it man
yeah
rich da vinnie ladies and gentlemen the
attributes 25 hidden drivers
of optimal performance will be linked in
the show notes below and
if they want to go and do their free
performance assessment and get all of
the tips they should go to
yeah the attributes.com it's all there
books there assessment tools there
workbooks they're there yeah
so um and you can contact me if you want
to if you want to you know get
consulting or
or speeches or keynotes or things like
that so all on the same website
all on the same website yeah try to make
it simple i love it dudes
thanks so much thank you my friend
thanks for having me
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace